let's talk about uh where we're going
domestically though we have this story
from timcast.com it's all from
timecast.com
pro-abortion protesters show up at the
home of justice kavanaugh hours after
man arrested for failed assassination
attempts so this story was from
yesterday
but you know this morning uh let me let
me tell you guys
you know about what happened last night
if you watched the show we were forced
to evacuate the building there was a
credible threat
it sucks
after we came back in
jeremy hambly of the quartering was
swatted and we believe by the same
person there were similarities to to the
incidents uh all those are ours was a
was substantially different there were
enough similarities to where we think it
was the same person
upon seeing that
you know so jeremy of the quartering
he's got a big youtube channel they
apparently pinned him on the ground
cuffed him they had pointed guns in the
face of his wife
and it's it's particularly brutal
i wake up and i see this story
that a man so so first let's let's go
back in time
people announce their intent to protest
at the homes of the supreme court
justices which is a federal crime
merrick garland says so what
genseki encourages it she says we
certainly encourage more of this she
outright said they encourage it they are
outright saying to commit crimes
and there's no justice
i warned
if people go to these homes and they are
not held to account and being held to
account means you get a slap on the
wrist they take you to the department
take a picture of you and you leave
you that you you go to court and the
judge says don't do it again and that's
the end of it just slap on the rest
nothing happens to you right but that
line is set that we will arrest you
because it's non-violent civil
disobedience i said if we don't do that
they will escalate to the next point
well they jumped the shark i mean the
next the next
escalation would have been like
vandalism but a dude shows up with zip
ties crowbar a knife a glocks i think a
glock 17.
yeah it's gonna be a bad night yeah it
was gonna be a very bad night and uh
this guy ends up uh confessing
turns himself in
and the protesters came back
and there's no justice unbelievable yeah
so
after everything we go through and we're
not that far away okay we're i don't
want to say just how close we are
relatively close
and there there's there's no justice
there's no law i can't see
people in this country having confidence
in the government when they know that
not only is one political faction
allowed to
just blatantly flagrantly break the law
but that they are encouraged to do so by
the white house press secretary and here
we are after assassination assassination
attempt the only thing i hope for is
that
they announced next week there's going
to be monday and wednesday opinion
rulings which is going to be big because
i believe this may be the last chance
they have to issue their opinions on roe
and casey and the gun control
legislation out of new york hopefully
brett kavanaugh sees this and he just
goes
people should have guns
constitutional carry nationwide love it
i certainly hope so otherwise i think
what we're looking at is
we've been swatted several times
we've had credible threats we had a
threat in nashville we were we were
going to play a show at john rich's
place and then we actually had a very
serious incident occur and they were
like we can't we can't do it there's
like kids and there's families
so we were forced to cancel it
this is the state of politics in this
country during the generation that
watched hannity you know rachel maddow
the older generation
they're not
they're not doing these things
you look at that splc poll that we
showed up we pulled up several uh uh
several times now the older generation
overwhelmingly does not favor political
assassinations right
young women
republican and democrat young men
republican and democrat over one-third
of all these
support political assassinations with
with democratic men being the highest at
44 of them supporting assassinations and
this is where we are which says to me
in the next 10 years
it's going to be
if this sentiment is this prominent
i could only imagine the next 10 15 and
20 years it's going to become mainstream
and normal to see this kind of violence
yeah i mean it
honestly it's this is and we talked
about a little bit yesterday this is the
value of human life issue it really is i
mean the fact that these people should
back up to brett kavanaugh's house
nobody even did were they not thinking
what about their kids what about their
wife what how are they feeling right now
they believe that they're that their
husband and that their father was just
you know the target of an assassination
you don't have any compassion well no
they don't they want power yeah and this
is the best opportunity for them in
their minds why brett kavanaugh is
scared someone just tried to kidnap and
murder him now the protest is a threat
yeah and they don't have to say the
words because it's already been made
yeah well and i would argue the protest
has been a threat the entire time what
is the purpose of protesting outside of
the home of someone who never has to run
for reelection who's in a lifetime
appointment you're not telling them that
they're going to lose at the ballot box
because public opinion is against them
no so what are you trying to show them
what are you trying to show them by
saying we are a bunch of angry people
outside of your house who don't want you
to make a particular decision yeah
you're trying to intimidate them i mean
exactly imagine being a person like oh
hey someone just tried to assassinate
that person and his family let's go
outside of his home and call him a liar
like what is wrong with people
it makes absolutely no rational sense at
all and where's the humanity you know
where where's the caring where's the
consideration of like hey maybe this is
not the best time to go scream at him
and his family they know they're allowed
to do it they have been encouraged to
break the law by the current
administration there are zero
consequences and if the way to get their
political agenda across and either
establish the social order that they
want to establish or protect what they
already have in place means that you
have to intimidate someone or they get
killed they are clearly okay with that
they are clearly completely comfortable
that and no one's talking about the fact
this guy had zip ties who who even says
he was just going after the justice
himself you're right he was outside of
his family's house he could have had a
plot to kidnap them and they're out
there the next day protesting it again
no not the next day afterwards literally
same day
hours hours 80 hours
every single democratic political leader
needs to be asked whether they disavow
this it doesn't matter exactly what
they're doing what's the point they know
what's the point of asking it right do
you think there's going to be a democrat
voter somewhere who's going to be like
i'm so surprised they supported the
thing i protested at that is a true
statement you know
there's there's no negotiating
maybe there are some regular people who
don't know all right we're driving in
the car with my buddy who doesn't pay
attention that much and i and i pick up
my phone i'm scrolling through twitter
and i go so there was a child drag show
in texas right and then he goes what and
then i was like what i was like well
that wasn't the point i was trying to
make i was going to say they were
protesters
but yeah you didn't know it's like what
do you mean child drag shows i'm like
these are happening all over the place
but they don't know what i mean but i
mean and so even i mean to go back to
the yesterday the the lawsuit that we've
we are waging against the these books
that are in schools that are sexually
explicit a lot of parents who has have
kids in schools they don't know that
these books are in there so so here's
the issue i'm getting to with this
watching these hearings the people who
are watching it if someone asks them do
you disavow this
the people at home the cognitive
dissonance the zombified democrat people
are going to be like
you you're you're in the other tribe you
want bad thing
you want but i agree with a certain
percentage but part of the reason the
left has been effective in their tactics
is because whenever they believe they
have found a reason to shame you they
hit you over the head with it over and
over and over and over again and so i
think it is an effective it's not just
an effective technique i think it's the
right thing to do to say hey do you do
you support this do you disavow this do
you have any kind of leg to stand on
when you talk about insurrection or
political violence or stability or
anything along those lines i think it's
a reasonable question and they do need
to be asked yeah i want to
just
if at the other side that if the
democrats aren't willing to speak
against this then they shouldn't speak
into january 6. i want to pull it this
way
oh i just want to make one more point if
they refuse to condemn something like
this it just totally undermines their
credibility with the center if there was
any that they had left with the center
obviously their political bases there's
no center the center is right-wing i
think there are some number of people
who would say like oh i think january
6th was serious or an insurrection or
they don't know any better but they
would not be on board with a commission
led by people who are okay with
assassin's creed i think tim's right
there isn't a center anymore because
they're calling you an extremist
they're calling me right the left is
yeah joe rogan is right wing yeah yes so
so not only is there no center but even
center leftists are right wing now right
yeah that that so let me let me pull
this street from jack vasovic yeah it's
important he tweets hi simon gwynne why
did you delete this huh and this is a
tweet from a uh let's see simon well
let's get let's let's pull this profile
what we got here a ukrainian flag so
he's trying to flag he supports current
things he tweeted
interesting real-life trolley problem in
america now if you had the chance to
kill clarence thomas or samuel alito the
two oldest right-wing supreme court
judges should you do it while biden can
get his nominees to replace them
confirmed that it's an interesting as an
abstract question but becomes a real
conundrum of say you're terminally ill
and have little to lose yourself
he's basically trying to incite someone
these people are insane they have
celebrated this stuff we need more than
ever you know people to back off yeah to
stop
they're not they're not being held
accountable for it there's no law
enforcement going after them you're
literally advocating crime let me tell
you something
uh we had a a tweet from keemstar do you
guys know keemstar yeah earlier keemstar
is a drama alert on youtube
apparently there was some dude who made
a joke about doxing someone at youtube
so they demonetized his channel took
away all of his revenue
what had happened was and this is just
for me watching a keemstar video so i
don't you guys fact check it but there's
some relevance here
he says
this guy got doxxed
he reached out to youtube and said hey
look someone published my private
information youtube said too bad so then
he made a joke saying oh okay so i guess
it's okay i could dox you right they
went boom demonetized his channel wow
what what ethan uh what's uh keemstar
then brings up is ethan klein
saying that he knows for a fact that
there were youtube employees at the nra
convention that ethan klein called to
bomb so ethan klein the host of the h3
podcast comparable size to this show
called on people to commit an act of
terror before very quickly walking it
back saying okay i got a little
passionate there got a little passionate
all that happened was a strike keemstar
said why would one guy get his entire
channel purged of all monetization
abilities
but ethan klein can call for a terror
attack right and all he gets is a strike
well that raises a question that i
wanted to raise sorry before we move on
we were talking about how this guy who
came to the to kavanaugh's house how did
he know where to go oh right because
they put directions to kavanaugh's house
on social media why is that still up why
is ethan klein allowed to call for an
actual terror attack and they allow it
they they took the video down they did
suspend him they gave he was passionate
he was passionate yeah that's true but
he also probably had any creativity he
wasn't just it wasn't just that he said
i was just joking he also told people to
take guns
yeah go outside the home of a governor
and fire them into the air which is just
insane
he also
seemed to believe that an ar-15 is fully
auto because when he said to get your
ar-15s and fire him he went
like that
like he thought it was full auto and
then when i guess his producer said no
no that's dangerous you can't do that
comes bolts come down he goes well
blanks then blanks are fine right and
it's like either way the dude actively
called for his audience to commit acts
of uh um
assault with deadly weapons wow and what
happened a single strike
a single strike alex jones got banned
from youtube for making a metaphor about
battle rifles well would i be safe in
assuming that the address for
kavanaugh's house is still up on the
protesters like on the pretty sure it is
yeah it's still up on their organizers
page i mean how is that legal how is
that legal i have no idea yeah i got
fully demonetized for years for i don't
know what just doing what i'm doing here
on this show talking about your current
learning issues you did confront the ceo
of google yes
he wasn't really happy but that's
another thing luke's i was asking did
you know luke's been to epstein island
no how was that
we're back in this conundrum yeah good
work how do i explain this
so so the first time i brought it up
luke didn't catch
what it sounds like it sounds like he
was invited there yeah like i was one of
the you know pervy presidents or you
know
tech guys that you know ceos that was
heading there and no no no no i i
crashed it afterwards and he did some
investigation yeah yeah so after was
already cleared out he got in a boat and
did some investigation there but likely
story yeah
luke just happened to have old footage
he's like how do i convince people i
wasn't really
i take it back you can't be president
yeah
sorry no that means i can't be president
okay so but seriously in in all reality
why why are we at a spot as a nation
that even that joke
has some some truth to it like come on
man because maxwell was convicted no no
it's just it's so sad that that's where
we're at it really is i think it's funny
that there was a poll
and it was like 57 of republicans
believe that the the country is being
run by a cabal of pedos or whatever and
i'm just like i mean the epstein thing
is proven to be real right like i'm not
surprised people are like bill clinton
flew on that plane and then they believe
that
it's it's it what are they trying to
claim with these with you know with
these news stories
it's kind of hard to deny it honestly oh
you got it there's no transparency
there's no there's nothing about that
trial that's out and it's only
scratching the surface right this is
what we know publicly still majority of
that is still behind the scenes it's
still held in secret it's still
classified
the documents have been sealed in that
case right so there is still it's sealed
because the judge said some of the
details here are so shocking and
salacious the general public can't see
this this is this is what the judge
ruled in that specific case so you could
only imagine this is what we're we're
getting from the outside point of view
only one percent of of what is really
happening but nobody's standing outside
of that judge's house
and protection that's very true or or
demanding for those documents to be
unsealed or for the information to make
public light or for those victims to
truly get justice for all of the
horrible things that they have to go
through while of course police officers
judges prosecutors if the fbi
intelligence agencies were all looking
the other way that's another aspect of
this that really should make you wonder
and it's you know what's happening right
now is is just the epitome of not
holding power to account and this is
what happens this is routinely what
happens when you allow people to get
away with these things they're going to
try to get away with bigger and bigger
things uh as time goes on and i think
this is the phase that we're in right
now an extremely dangerous phase for
everyone and how is it a political issue
that's the thing i don't understand when
people are hurting little kids and
you're sexually exploiting little kids
how is this a partisan issue
this should be a human issue the left
look i see these memes all day on
facebook they're saying things like
republicans don't want anyone to know
that some people have two dads and i'm
like i'm pretty sure republicans are mad
that the book they're getting challenged
has a picture of adult you know
activities with one person you know
going down and they're like what
and i'm like okay dude if you get your
news from memes on on facebook you're
probably gonna be misinformed a hundred
percent they they they genuinely believe
that republicans are complaining because
a book showed a kid with two deads and
i'm like well look some
sure yeah but are you going to single
out that or you're going to focus on
what the news story is actually about
the book genderqueer i was like if you
look at loudoun county they're talking
about a book that shows a white hand
from white person with a devil tale
coming out demonizing white people
outright i'm like yeah i'm i'm not
surprised that people are upset about
racism but you didn't actually read
anything you just believe whatever
rachel maddow says right so you have no
idea what's going on and the their issue
so for for us those two books that we've
put forth in this lawsuit only thing
we're asking for is parental consent
parental consent for parents
for for minors to view sexually explicit
material very simple restoring parental
rights that's all the problem is is that
these two books
are really pg compared to some of the
other books that are in in circulation
in the public schools i mean there are
books in schools that
have a six-year-old girl
bound and gagged and gang-raped
like this this is in the public school
system but people are acting like it's
not a big deal have you ever read
stephen king
stephen king should we give that to
sixth graders though probably not well i
i honestly
i don't know do schools have stephen
king novels in their libraries too
maybe not i mean because they're adult
they're polygraphic but i don't i don't
you know what's funny is most people
have seen his movies they've not read
his books right
yo
if you read those stories you're going
to be like uh
hold on there a minute i can't get into
them they're way too dark for me it's
not about the doc well i mean yeah it's
like
most people don't realize that there's a
lot of graphic uh adult scenes among
children in those books
another reason not to like it yeah i
remember i
remember people
you're not selling it for me that's
disgusting i remember people mentioning
that after it came out is that the case
with is that like a sig i mean
regardless disgusting i didn't know that
that was uh a theme with the rest of his
oh yeah that's the thing books that is
so yeah yeah i just don't understand how
that well i get actually given the
behavior of the fbi i do understand how
that flies that's a theme and you watch
stephen king on twitter and you're like
oh yeah this all makes sense here's the
issue though if you look at throughout
throughout human history societies fall
civilizations fall when
when they're paying their military the
least entertainment the most and they're
focused on sexuality you look at over
and over again these are some of the key
issues that have revolved around some
civilizations falling and look at where
we're at as a nation we really have the
degradation and destruction of
civilization usually has these final
steps i i i saw a meme out there with a
child talking to the the dog people who
were dressed in their full fetish
behaviors and uh you know the meme read
this is this is how civilizations
collapse
correct yeah it's disgusting well think
i mean think about it right you look at
the the left's entire mission and it has
been for decades um if not centuries is
to just break down all sexual morality
and what taboos are left there right
what taboos have yet to be broken down i
kind of those are the ones that they're
going to try to do away with i'm sorry
it's been their mission it's look at
alfred kinsey the one thing the one
thing that all of these
these cultural shifts they're trying to
push have in common is less children
every single one for one they're
outright saying don't have kids the
environment right then they're saying
they're they're encouraging activities
that don't result in having kids they're
encouraging abortion they encourage
meaningful sex it's not all bad birth
control tell kids to you know birth
control and and condoms and
prophylactics and all that stuff i those
are fine but all of it
it's like hey all of these things result
in less kids
the child transitioning
less kids sterilization of the
sterilization of an entire generation
that's potentially yeah the birth
control thing should also be talked
about uh skeptically because there is
some data and science coming out that is
very troubling surrounding that
specifically
yeah we uh we mass medicate young girls
yeah that's what they're all messing
with their hormones from their teeth
that they can't go back from yeah create
damages that are
with them for the rest of their lives
well yeah playing hormone block putting
people in hormone blockers and they act
like it's reversible it's not it's not
well and then you know you look at
contraceptives in general and the idea
that you would take this profound and
beautiful human interaction which
creates new life and totally shift the
cultural understanding of it as this is
just something that's for fun right and
it's i mean no wonder well the
societal breakdown and it's also
interesting because our society is
totally two-faced with it right it's
like have sex have sex have sex have sex
never have children never have children
never have children well i'm sorry one
leads to the other it's very it's like
do not the way they're telling you to do
it yeah that's right no i i understand
that every push results in less kids
yeah yeah there you go and and it's no
surprise i mean people like bill gates
he did ted talk on this he said we need
to reduce population growth well it's no
surprise then that he and many other
support programs that result either it
reminds me of that simpsons episode
where they remember they joined the navy
thing yes when they play the boy band
song yeah
and then the recruiter is explaining to
lisa how he does it he's like we do he's
like subliminal liminal and super
liminal and she's like super liminal and
he goes yeah and he opens the window hey
you join the navy and then lenny and
carl are like all right
and then later you see him getting on
the bus like that's all it took that's
what i feel like you've got the the
subliminal which is the you should be on
birth control you know having kids a
nightmare don't have kids where they
outright are just saying like oh it's
bad it's worse just have fun and engage
in these lifestyles then you have the
super liminal which is just outright
being like the environment is hurting
and it's your fault for having kids so
don't have kids and then you have the
kind of unconscious uh chemical
castration of individuals as even some
fish off the coast of florida were found
to have antidepressants within their
system because the the pills the big
pharma are never truly dealt with
they're just kind of pushed on into a
different kind of um
in different kind of environment where
you know fish take them we eat the fish
we get affected by these specific big
pharma pills that there's no getting rid
of that's another aspect of it well you
know historically obviously you had you
know classes of people who didn't have
children but generally at least in the
west and in christendom those people
were celibate and they were focused on
other things they were contributing in
really serious and significant ways now
what we're doing is is we're ensuring
that virtually all of the population
either doesn't have children or they
don't have children at replacement right
and we just keep them distracted
with um
non-procreative sex and whatever new
gadget comes out that they want to buy
and so it's not as if the energy that
would be expended towards having
children and raising a family is placed
into some other arena which is
productive for the culture society as a
whole it's all just thrown in to seeking
base pleasure right which is why i mean
so for me moving forward one of the
things that i'm i'm passionate about
focusing on is protecting the family
unit i think the family i mean is the
basic building block of society and we
have to protect the family unit yeah
well and you mentioned this right one of
the signs of a declining society is this
obsession with sex and part of the
reason that there has to be this
obsession is so you can break down the
barriers because the sex is the building
block of the family which is the
building block of the society and if you
can corrupt the understanding of that
you can tear everything else down thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there